no you should do with your commie I know
you're like super famous not bad but we
should do is in Boston book the same
weekend as Joe Rogan and then when
you're in Denver book the same weekend
as Chris D'Elia is that what's going on
in you know what though ya know so it
helps my sound good
I'm almost sold how could do both I'm
almost sold out in Boston but that's the
thing people go why would he book the
same way years D'Elia same weekend as
Rogan yeah but the thing is you're
you're at different venues yeah and you
can see delete on Friday fan of comedy
see Brown and sadder that's right I feel
like it helps 2%
well my numbers are I'm selling better
than I've ever sold in Boston and and
dinner so you know a lot of that could
be that also they know that I'm better
than than Joe and Chris I just mean like
overall like as far as funnier better
no no just dislike be [ __ ] yeah I just
mean as a comic like when you go like
with me with Chris and Joe okay that's
all right I just mean that I'm better
that's what I do yeah he was that for
you or he was that but he posted a
picture just to cheers Brian they're
setting up for your show what you did
it's so funny laughing no choice but to
hook up with your wife no it's not what
what please do please do please do
please get me out of here so I got a
freebie
Jim you don't want to bang from the
Brenin yeah there are some girls yeah
there was some girls my business partner
OJ Simpson I find by the way here's the
truth if you did if you did for your a
my your Hall Pass em I mean I that the
problem is we couldn't it couldn't be
like if we were like they're not exactly
sure why like this would be like you
banned my wife I'm never speaking you
again in this would be like you know
dude now the podcasts gonna be super
awkward
see there that's like we have Brian out
of the singer AJ and I go dude you hear
about Brian show you in particular of
course I heard about a girl hell yeah
man this is really crazy year we're just
talking
he's like both you guys may have so
proud of you guys and you know Brennan
had an article in Wall Street Journal
about success no big deal yeah I know
it's stupid no um so we're coming back
strong journalist so we're going back to
your Wall Street Journal I don't read it
then the thing is is so then we were
going back and forth and he goes god man
with the firing the kid like do you just
I don't know man you guys were so busy I
mean prime to be doing this should be
doing this like well where are you going
with this story right now yeah no
neither one I ask that my Jimmy Burke my
dear dear friends like now are you gonna
do that if I don't I go well yeah that's
what got me here in a lot of ways my
case it's also like this to this isn't
work to me I'm never I don't not once
I've ever worked up like [ __ ] man no I
get to go and hang out with my friend
and no hawk the way I would anyway and
people on the road go do have like how
much like stuff do you guys write down
before the show you ready never once
have we ever in doubt make sure we talk
about this mad once we did go through a
phase where I cut where we're like
should we like talk beforehand about
what we're gonna talk about and we're
like we could try it never have never
happened doesn't work no Calvin aqus
it's true that confidence is heaven's
house built in here in town and he and
when they'd have to they're like we have
to put another wall up here there's got
to be a retaining wall it's gonna cost
another 30 grand or hunter grant or
whatever Hank oh um you know now I got
to do another shitty movie to afford
this he would storm off and the road
workers starting this serious is you
guys can't like measure how [ __ ]
amazing Bobby DS oh my watching
Goodfellas you other night and you say
oh yeah casino but I would you speaking
of people who Punk me Ray Liotta Punk me
too really yeah how so woody min we I
was at a UTA party which is like a big
agency here in LA my wife is represented
by them or was I believe and we it was a
Oscars UTA party and I'm like [ __ ] I'm
in Black Tie get to go and hung up with
the best you know the biggest thing
let's do this so we go to this party and
I feel
mildly insecure about being there
because hey I'm I'm some chicks white
husband I'm not even an actor or Lita
and we're there and Ray Liotta from
across the room makes a beeline for us I
mean like he's staring at my wife and I
within 10 yeah walking towards us and he
goes right in my wife's face do you you
uh you're that girl you're that girl
from the show the show and she goes
rules of engagement he's like yeah
you're fantastic I love that show I love
you and she goes oh thank you so much
you know means a lot coming from you
yeah yeah and this is your husband the
soccer player I should thought you were
[ __ ] uh and I don't know no he thought
I was my wife's ex-husband Landon
Donovan oh [ __ ] no I'm the new husband
yes Oh Oh what do you do I go I man on
radio it's got nothing on you bro he's
fertilize them no I disagree he's not
good-looking dude any well listen I may
be saleable more of a dime piece but
he's a great sloppy marginally
considered the greatest American soccer
player ever you see his body but it's
unbelievable I was like he's the best
example of I need for hormone
replacement but but another example of
it doesn't it you know it does help but
you know you do still have skills is
over him yeah he was juiced to the
[ __ ] gills and was no it's just
steroids he gets officer it's still
number one in the world right [ __ ]
pretty [ __ ] good but I do think I do
think it helps you're teachin
I don't sleep a lot of like scientific
really and I were talking about this
well I don't know what it is I don't
know the science behind it but there's
something about when you're on test guys
can take shots that they can't when
they're awful yeah it has something to
do with like split second reaction time
as you get hit the difference probably
between this like there wasn't this and
that because
I'm gonna help with that like that
sounds like you be fast reaction time
but it doesn't know hormone will mm
maybe but the thing is with with
testosterone maybe it strengthens the
muscles in your neck does it make you
more aggressive though so you tend to be
more you're more willing to get step
into the shot as opposed to pull back I
don't think so those guys are aggressive
anyways I think if anything may be
strengthened because it's starting
something we can eat bigger shots that
seems the most reasonable is that face
it's like you keep peeling it maybe John
Cena has a buff face yes now dudes a
buff face I wonder if fat dad like Mark
Khan's never touch the steroid in his
life just take a shot yeah but then you
look at like Moen you look at Bigfoot
Silva who needed testosterone just to
live right because he had thyroid in a
giant ism and when he got off of it guys
are like and he'd get knocked out but
then he's on it you know when the
greatest heavyweight fight he's not he's
illiterate like truly a [ __ ] up
situation like he he should he should
get an exemption he has a maturity
though or half that but look how good he
is with it with it with testosterone
like he's a [ __ ] one of the best of
all time yeah you know he's top ten he
beat you know monster intimately born
with something that prevents him having
normal and maybe don't compete maybe you
should be a fighter because it is unfair
because look off of it still has never a
champion still got beaten by guys